President Trump is now being sued by a
porn star a reality star and a Playboy
model that's what that's what we're
looking at yes yes porn star reality
star played Wilma yeah or as Trump's
evangelical supporters call that be Holy
Trinity that's just people upset that
President Trump called Vladimir Putin to
congratulate him yeah and let's check
this out in addition to President Trump
it turns out kim jeong-hoon also called
putin to congratulate him on his
election victory yeah whoo yeah Putin
said afterwards well I'm hearing from
all the crazies
[Applause]
I'm like Trump my hair starts somewhere
back here and I pulled it all forward my
hair starts at my low back
yeah just teased it all forward think
about that on the way home
did you know that's during president
Trump's called of Vladimir Putin he
congratulated the Russian leader despite
a message from his staff that was right
in front of him that read do not
congratulate do not congratulate yeah
which is why today Melania sent him a
message that read do not divorce
quickies whatever you two please that
one was ok but will applaud afterwards
youtube is planning a Karate Kid series
that follows the characters 34 years
later yeah
the show is entitled Ralph Macchio's
mortgages do
thank you thank you thank you I just
[ __ ] on a guy who's probably very nice
hey the Queen of England is planning a
huge concert for her 92nd birthday
concert yeah yeah the Queen made the
decision right after finding out that
pitbull was available
so what's a Gucci Mane maybe it's Gucci
Mane pitbull is it gucci mane and yes
there is a person named no no I said you
know is that unacceptable who here knows
who Gucci Mane is that's like a third of
the crowd yeah we debated this backstage
yeah yeah we were gonna go out there and
just say Gucci Mane right and we had all
these you almost saying you got to do it
man
people love it if you said gucci mane
that's like I'm not sure everyone the
crowds gonna know who Gucci Mane is nope
how about Jimmy Carter that was 45
percent of you
you